Souths isolating and social distancing
doesn't mean you can't enjoy live music
Brad Paisley proved that on Thursday
night with a star-studded livestream
concert featuring just a few of country
music's biggest stars hi everybody well
this is the craziest production I've
ever tried to do so I'm gonna basically
take any requests you guys might have
tonight and play as much as we can get
away with before everybody gets bored
with his wife and actress Kimberly
Williams Paisley operating the camera
Brad put on an hour-long show from his
home studio in front of an audience of
stuffed animals yeah the singer kicked
off the set with mud on the tires before
Carrie Underwood joined him for a
virtual performance of their duet remind
me
[Music]
all now what do you say
I can hardly wait
I feel bad you missed your flight that
man
[Music]
baby
[Applause]
[Music]
and that wasn't the only familiar face
Brad called the one and only Tim McGraw
for a cover of George Strait to the
firemen and for the final special guest
Chris Young joined the video chat for
performance of Brad's hit I'm still a
guy that
[Music]
but when you say backpack rooming zone
and backrub
[Music]
what can I say
[Music]